all right today's topic uh something
happened at the Pittsburgh Steelers game
so we want to cover it
[Applause]
[Music]
she hit him first
somebody get his glasses
[Music]
what are your thoughts go for people are
saying yeah but he touched the first
nose he pushed her and he said don't
touch me because he went to touch him
she went to touch him and then she
slapped him you can have this
disagreement you could have
disagreements and that's all good does
everybody get disagreements that's all
that's all good that's gender equality
right there I'm not saying women man
none of that or every any anyone in
between
the minute you lay your hands on someone
see that mosquito bite see that mosquito
try to get at you and then you slap the
[__]
same thing
keep your sting to yourself that's it
I'm gonna do this in two parts first
part part number one okay there's a lot
of men out there who have to have a
conversation with their woman about
violence
because women
are out here writing checks that they're
boys they're husbands
this man got knocked out because his or
his wife couldn't keep her cool here's
the thing men walk through life and they
understand the threat of violence okay
that's why no no no listen no no listen
listen I'm gonna talk about it okay I
see this all the time men walk around
and if you're five foot tall all right
and you're substantially weaker than a
six foot three guy you're not gonna talk
some [__] or get up in the space because
you're gonna get dead and No One's Gonna
feel bad for nobody but women even with
their physical inferiority still feel so
comfortable going into situations where
these dudes could kill them with ease
and what ends up happening well the man
that you're with he has to defend you
but maybe he's not even strong enough to
do so so now he's getting knocked out
getting brain damage because he has to
protect a stupid ass person who doesn't
understand the consequences of violence
and I'm not saying this to joke and
laugh around I don't know how badly that
man got hurt and you won't know either
because when you get dipped on your head
it's hanging like this right when you go
full Stephen Hawking on people that's
permanent so a lot of ladies are getting
men into violent situations that they
themselves can't handle they instigate
it take the minimal amount of damage and
their boys get stomped out because you
best believe if she goes crazy to a
group of six men and that guy defends
he's gonna take to stop it he's not her
she'll think a couple slaps maybe a
punch or two he's gonna get beat
because even men would rather beat up
another dude than beat up a woman but
they will do it sometimes yeah but you
can't do it yeah but you don't know who
you're facing you don't know who the
person in front of you he shouldn't do
it but there's a lot of things that
shouldn't be done and people still do it
yeah right you don't know who you have
in front of you and who's going to be
willing to do what Keep Your Hands to
Yourself ladies and don't threaten
violence all right you shouldn't hit a
date lady don't do the right but you
shouldn't hit a man either don't say you
want to box people randomly don't don't
do that because it might come to you
they might just break down your door
come on stop stop
hey stop stop it don't don't bring that
violence don't do not lay your hands if
you don't want that don't talk about it
no put it out there don't talk about it
don't put your hands out there don't
manhandle someone keep your hands to
yourself that's why in an argument
there's some people that argue like this
so everybody know that was not the first
one but if you so happen to touch me
that's some hood [__] right here I ever
seen someone in that yo yo yo yo you
want to do this you want to know you
want to know how a [__] about to fight
you if he starts doing
you're standing looking at him he's like
he's just getting ready yeah he's
breaking that [__] up dude he's cranking
that [__] up and the one that does this
is yo I'm not gonna do the first try but
once you do it's it's it's it's it's a
whole square and that square is up no
don't mention it don't talk to people
y'all [__] you up when you're not and
also I also want to give a shout out to
the guy who who knocked both the asses
my man was playing the role of Anakin
Skywalker in Star Wars even with the low
ground he would have [__] up only one
makers
he was connecting clean so shout out to
him that technique's on point and like I
said some of you might say Abba but that
response is not proportionate she just
slapped him you don't know what people
have been through you know you don't
know what how people I respond to
physical touch especially when it's
unwarranted I got no problem with a
woman slapping a man if he grabs her ass
you have no right to be putting your
hands on nobody and I keep that same
energy with ladies when you guys put
your hands in a man's face but a slap is
not proportional to your ass grabbing
who says emotional it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter who said that it doesn't
matter I ain't mad if the guy flat [__]
him up nope nope it doesn't have to be a
proportional if you go out here and you
instigate violence the response doesn't
have to be proportional that's crazy
it's not like this man pulled out a gun
you slapped him he punched you and he's
within his rights because you violated
his boundaries you don't have to slap
someone be like slap me back that's not
the way it works once you cross that
boundary you win the you win a whole
other ball you go 20 of your train I go
20 of mine yeah don't be doing all that
crazy stuff so guys just just be mindful
of that don't instant gain no violence
that's pretty much it that's all I gotta
say because it might come to you ladies
watch this ladies watch this this is
something y'all
I see too many guys get knocked out all
right for a woman that was undeserved
sorry
[Music]
everybody
babies
[Music]